I think i've just found out what they're
hiding down here this place isn't a fortress
Hello there everyone this is going to be my full
star wars obi-wan kenobi episode 4 video there's
a bunch of easter eggs so if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
episodes we're doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships too all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite easter egg
for the episode on the video and of course careful
for spoilers for the episode if you haven't seen
it yet because we'll be talking about everything
the sound of all those fingers trying to figure
out who all those different jedi were because
some of them were featured during the clone
wars episodes so most of the ones that they
actually focus the camera on are meant to be
big easter eggs and i'll talk about that when
we get to that part of the video as per usual
they start the episode with the obi-wan kenobi
theme that john williams created it's meant to
be a blend of that theme from a new hope when
he finds luke skywalker's body for the first
time unfurling his hood revealing his identity
the actual opening scene also very following up on
that is obi-wan kenobi waking up from his torture
at darth vader's hands after force choking him
and dragging him through the fire now he's been
burned like anakin skywalker bird on mustafar
but not nearly as bad like they look like minor
flesh wounds compared to what happened to anakin
skywalker you feel a little bit of his rage later
in the episode and you only see bits of him early
in the episode too so i'll explain because in some
parts it's hayden christensen as darth vader and
then when he's actually wearing the armor it's
actually a different actor because he's meant to
be so tall like it's a giant walking around in
that armor when he was wearing the armor darth
vader was about seven feet tall which is crazy
tall but we see tala's character taking obi-wan
kenobi to their resistance base we meet a couple
of the other characters but they have a minor
ragtag crew mostly they use this to juxtapose
his ptsd and his flashbacks to their reunion
fight together with darth vader's flashbacks
because when you see him in the back this tank
for the first time and it is the first time that
we've seen obi-wan kenobi actually in a back
to tank they actually directly flash between
his scenes in the tank and him remembering the
fight in darth vader scenes in his tank in his
ship so when they're flashing to vader in the
tank all these scenes are meant to be current
present day like both of them are replaying the
events of their reunion fight in their minds
darth vader still obsessed with obi-wan kenobi
still trying to capture him that's all he cares
about right now he could care less about what's
happening with leia remember during this part of
the timeline he doesn't know anything about her
being his daughter so he's only thinking about
obi-wan kenobi reba is the one who captured her
and is trying to find all the information about
the jedi path the survivors of order 66 so that
the empire will give her more props for finding
all these other jedi survivors out there quinlan
vos is off there somewhere on jabim just waiting
to come out and kick some butt but they do confirm
that reba took leia to the fortress inquisitorius
like literally it's just a jump cut like we're
already there if it felt like the episode moved
really quickly after the events of last week's
episode it was probably the shortest episode
that they have in the series it's about the same
length that you would expect from the mandalorian
episodes like there's some that are really short
but usually they're closer to like 40-42 minutes
you don't see the entire fortress inquisitors in
this episode but they do give you a tour some of
the places that we haven't been before obviously
the biggest one being where they're housing all
those jedi that they captured and if you did play
jedi fallen order or if you've seen anything from
that game the fortress inquisitors is featured
heavily during that but it's meant to be as close
as possible as the version that you saw during
jedi fallen order they explained it's on a moon
called nur in the mustafar system they call it
vader system because obviously mustafar revenge
of the sith references it's meant to be a system
that's very powerful in the dark side of the force
which is one of the reasons why the emperor
wanted darth vader to build his castle there
the emperor wanted darth vader to be more powerful
darth vader himself wanted to be more powerful
in one of the ways the sith would increase their
connection to the dark side of the force is to
just experience as many strong emotions as
possible for as long as possible for darth
vader that was to just be as angry as possible
for as long as possible which wasn't hard to do
pretty much at every point during the original
trilogy during rogue one everywhere he goes
everywhere in this part of the timeline he's full
of rage like when he walks in and starts yelling
at riva he's like that on the inside all the time
and even though a lot of the episode was meant to
show you how obi-wan kenobi is remembering a lot
of his force abilities like his technique with a
lightsaber literally got better throughout the
episode scene to scene when he's in a system
like the mustafar system this powerful in the dark
side of the force it also weakens his connection
to the light side of the force this would be like
running a marathon with a bunch of weights on like
it's just harder for him to do normal things that
he would be doing with the force all these early
scenes of riva interrogating leia are meant to
show you what she's like during a new hope and
mirror those scenes just resisting on every
single level but the other really big thing
that happens during this interrogation is that
riva basically gives you all of her backstory
during order 66 in right after order 66. if it
wasn't clear she's actually this young jedi here
during order 66 and she basically says that she
was captured she had a droid just like lola as she
says but it was taken from her like everything
else was taken from me you notice she tries
to reach into leia's mind using the force and
dominate it pick out information find out where
the hidden jedi went obviously the reason she
can't do it the same way that she did it to haja
earlier in the series is because she's so strong
in the force and she's subconsciously using it to
block reba there's been a couple moments during
the series where leia has subconsciously used
the force without actually thinking about the
force itself it'll be interesting to see if she
actively tries to use it at some point during the
series it's kind of like grogu at the beginning
of the mandalorian grogu had forgotten a
lot of his abilities kind of like obi-wan
had forgotten a lot of his more advanced jedi
abilities but you don't just turn off someone's
sensitivity to the force like they still have the
connection to the force so they can still use it
it's just they can't use it in quite a refined
way if they've forgotten some of their abilities
so leia is a little bit more like rogue at the
beginning of the mandalorian series you have all
this potential in the force and if you actually
tried to do something you could probably do
something but i think because they don't want
to break the timeline and leia didn't really
actively use the force as an adult during the
original trilogy we'll see her using it in more
practical subconscious ways like oh yes she's very
clearly force sensitive and she's using the force
now even if she's not thinking about actually
using the force but when we meet the new broken
character he calls obi-wan kenobi general so it
sounds like he fought in the clone wars he said
that he was married to a force-sensitive woman
who the inquisitors killed after order 66 the
way he talks about if she was captured and either
put in this orange fluid or just outright killed
when they get ready to take obi-wan kenobi to the
fortress inquisitorious and show you that gear
show you where the planet is to kind of give
you a once-over tutorial about what's going
on with the fortress itself like oh it's in the
mustafar system but it's not on mustafar let's
just differentiate it from the actual vader's
castle because vader's castle's on mustafar
but the forces inquisitorious is on one of the
moons nearby he also says darth vader stayed on a
ship behind i think that was for a couple reasons
narratively he's staying behind on his ship to
stay in his back the tank to regenerate because
he needs to also because he's waiting for obi-wan
kenobi to come out of hiding visibly so that he
can go after him again and recapture him and also
i think on a more practical level to keep darth
vader as far away from leia as possible at least
young leia so they don't interact too much i'll
talk about that in the next couple of episodes too
because i do expect them to share at least a very
brief scene it would be weird if they don't share
at least one really small scene either way i think
that's the reason why he doesn't show up at the
fortress till the very end of the episode after
they've already taken off there's a whole funny
scene with them trying to break into the fortress
inquisitorius tala says that she can use her older
codes that's meant to be a reference return of
the jedi where they break into the forest moon
of endor using the older codes when tala helps him
break in underwater to the fortress that's meant
to be an easter egg for both phantom menace when
he's swimming to the gungan city underwater and
to fall in order because you entered the fortress
underwater a lot of you also asked me about the
timeline too the events of jedi fallen order also
take place around 10 years or so after revenge of
the sith so it's around the same time period they
said at the whole running story line with obi-wan
kenobi on his search and rescue mission slowly
regaining his force abilities or remembering his
forced techniques now he's not remembering how to
be connected to the force you don't forget that
but that's what he means when he says you don't
forget something like that like you don't forget
the force it's a bit like riding a bicycle and
it's the same thing for grogu for the most part
too like he was only with luke skywalker for
a very brief period during book of boba fett
but luke said that he managed to remember most of
all the teachings that he forgot over the years
that's why by the end of the episode when he's
fighting against the stormtroopers he's swinging
his lightsaber around deflecting blaster shots
like it's no big deal for those of you that were
worried about him not being skilled during the
last big reunion fight that they had in episode 3
you can kind of see what they're doing with this
too is it means that the next time that he and
darth vader have a rematch he will be much more
skilled and it'll be much more like their fight
the technique during their fight during revenge
of the sith but that's basically what obi-wan
is doing throughout the episode especially
these early parts is just trying to use the
force in small ways to sort of remember things
one of the other interesting things that you
notice here though is that as tala is breaking
in going past the security guard she lies to
him about the grand inquisitor he does not
seem to know anything about him being dead
deborah chow and the other people that worked
on the show said that canon is very important
to them and the inquisitor are still alive later
in the timeline so i think when they were trying
to answer these questions about the inquisitor
potentially being dead they were trying to say
no no no don't worry we secretly did not kill him
he's going to come back in a really big way by
the finale so that's an early prediction right now
is that we'll see some big reveal in the end with
the inquisitor coming back sort of like anakin
skywalker coming back as darth vader like you'd
be surprised at what a sith warrior can survive
that's also probably why riva got him with a gut
shot instead of a head shot everyone posting their
thanos memes you should have gone for the head
there are a couple new characters that we haven't
seen in earlier episodes before i don't think that
we saw death troopers before but we do see them
during rogue one later in the timeline and we see
a seeker droid and i think that's the first time
on the series that they've shown a secret droid it
just looks like a smaller pro droid it does have
a stun weapon that it tries to get him with later
when riva is interrogating leia also trying to get
her to continue to lose hope she keeps telling her
the people you care about will never come save
you no one is coming for you it's all meant to
be her trying to use her own fear like riva's fear
as a child against leia so it was meant to reveal
how riva wound up turning to the dark side of the
force and becoming an inquisitor and why she hates
these jedi survivors so much the people that
survived order 66 because at the time when she
was captured after order 66 the jedi inquisitors
at that time or the fallen jedi working with the
emperor who worked to create the inquisitorius
used all that same fear against her trying to
twist her against the other jedi saying that all
these other jedi ran they don't care about you at
all so why should you care about them at least
in riva's case she turned to the dark side and
now she's hunting them down because she resents
what they did not do coming to help save her
the whole point of the series is to flow into new
hope to show obi-wan kenobi finding new hope like
he's meant to start the series at his lowest point
it's also meant to be a parallel for riva story 2
i think even though it seems like she's about to
get her comeuppance from someone like the other
inquisitors hate her darth vader seems like he
hates her now the grand inquisitor definitely
wants to kill her even if she survives by the end
it sounds like she will also find some new hope
towards the end of the series leia lying to her
too trying to use her father against her is just
trying to show her resisting more more practical
resistance like resisting through the force
because she can't read her mind but also being
stubborn enough to just not give that information
up but when obi-wan kenobi finds the wing where
they're keeping all those jedi he uses a special
cylinder to open it those are the cylinders that
you see on all the imperial uniforms sometimes
they'll have multiple cylinders on their uniforms
those are meant to be code cylinders that will
give them access to special hidden areas or
special databases it's like when you see r2d2
sticking his arm into other computers to access
them it's the same thing for imperials but they
use those small cylinders this is probably the
most part of the episode though is him finding all
the bodies of these jedi the very first jedi that
he sees here is actually jedi master tara sunube
who showed up during the clone wars episodes that
a lot of you might remember he's notable because
his lightsaber was disguised as his walking stick
so he's able to walk around hiding his true power
probably the most reveal here though is the jedi
youngling who's still in his gear from the jedi
temple in order 66 like they literally just stuck
him inside this facility after the end of order
66. let me know if you think you know who all
these other jedi are now there are a couple of
different rows they don't show us every single row
so you have to imagine that is pretty much most of
the jedi and it sounds like everybody that darth
vader captures the inquisitor's capture that they
just stick in here the other reason why darth
vader kept them like this is to keep them like
trophies just like their lightsabers that they
took off of them when the inquisitors captured
them if you look in the background there are two
different display cases on both sides of the door
those are the lightsabers that they took off
of the jedi that are inside this facility
riva putting little leia a little 10 year old
girl on this wicked looking torture device here
is just meant to give you echoes for a new
hope of her being tortured by darth vader
but eventually with a little bit of help from tala
who tries to distract reba obi-wan kenobi is able
to save her using the darkness and you do see his
jedi abilities slowly becoming stronger throughout
these scenes and through their hallway escape they
do this really cool thing too where they try to
illuminate them only using the red light from the
floor it's meant to give you very sith echoes red
is a very dark jedi very sith color so you see red
lights casting red shadows on everything all over
the fortress inquisitorius tala gives us a really
big easter egg in connection to star wars rebels
also to the clone wars when she says the rebels
are actually on florum it's actually meant to be a
big callback to leia lying about the rebels being
on dantooine when really they were on yavin 4 but
also this is a callback to the clone wars to star
wars rebels because florum is a planet that hondo
comes from the scene of obi-wan kenobi holding
off the stormtroopers in the hallway fight as
the glass starts to crack is also pretty cool
his ability with a lightsaber seems like it's
getting closer and closer to what it was during
revenge of the sith the other big connection here
too is if you played jedi fallen order one of
the ways they escaped darth vader during that
game in the fortress inquisitors is by breaking
the glass and flooding the area just distracting
vader for a little while while they get away this
time though they actually bring back around that
big snow speeder easter egg from earlier when
obi-wan kenobi says you have a bunch of t-47s
oh but they've been retrofitted to carry a bunch
of sewage those are the same ships that are the
snow speeders from empire strikes back r.i.p wade
though who winds up eating a bunch of energy cells
when riva force pushes them into him they also
have a funny callback to a new hope with the
mouse droid that bites it during this fight scene
then they finally bring back darth vader like i
said for a couple reasons i think mostly just to
keep him away from leia until the later episodes
riva only saving herself from being forced choked
into oblivion by revealing that she placed a
tracker on layla's lola droid at the beginning of
the episode they were talking about taking them to
jabim so it sounds like that's where they're going
in this episode but remember at this point in the
timeline they're not called the rebels they're
not like this unified force of figures yet they're
just like a couple pockets of resistance all over
the galaxy trying to work together helping each
other during the events of the andor rogue
one prequel series we'll see the rebellion
actually come together but again i think the
big thing here is them swerving on having leia
interact with darth vader in any scenes or them
being in proximity to each other that is i think
until the later episodes like it would be weird if
they don't at least share a small scene together
the other weird thing of note during the episode
is when riva spent all that time interrogating
leia you think that she would sense that leia was
force sensitive leia just going full stealth in
the force i guess mostly for continuity plot
armor's sake though i think like they didn't
want the empire finding out that leia was a force
sensitive character because then that would have
caused bigger problems later in the timeline
the whole thing with leia smiling and grabbing
obi-wan kenobi's hand looking at him him smiling
back is meant to foreshadow his renewed hope like
i said the series is all about him finding new
hope again for the future it's a bit of a double
meaning though like the title of new hope means
a lot of different things like it's a reference
to obi-wan kenobi's hope it's a reference to luke
skywalker himself to leia because she is also a
new hope for the galaxy but also a new hope that
anakin skywalker will resurface inside darth vader
and redeem himself somehow so it's like
a reference to like four different things
just to clarify too the reason why you see hayden
christensen's name in the credits even though you
don't see a ton of him is because any time darth
vader is out of the armor in the back to anytime
it's like an actual human body that you're seeing
that is hayden christensen wearing that makeup and
when you hear darth vader's voice as james earl
jones they're actually using the same trick they
use for luke skywalker's voice during the book of
boba fett episodes more recently i will tolerate
your weakness no longer where you're hearing is
a digital recreation of james earl jones voice
in a computer sort of like a cobbled together
version of his voice made up out of nothingness
so james earl jones who's in his 90s now still
doing great did not come in to record this new
dialogue it was the same thing for mark hamill
and luke skywalker during book of boba fett
mark hamill said i did not record any new
dialogue they did all that in a computer
the whole thing now though is the inquisitors
and darth vader are going to try and follow
the tracker to jabim and find their resistance
base wherever they're hiding out for those of
you hoping for quinlan vos cameo scene
because the way that tala talked about
him he was a big part of this underground jedi
railroad if you spotted any big easter eggs in
the episode that i didn't talk about in the
video just write them below in the comments
my full obi-wan kenobi episode 5 video will post
next week just like normal because there's so much
big stuff happening today and starting today
my next big video will be for the black adam
trailer and then my full ms marvel episode 1
video will post ms marvel will also be a weekly
series but what will happen is because they both
post on the same day as i'll do my obi-wan kenobi
episode videos first because there's only a couple
left and then i'll post my miss marvel videos
make sure to enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss anything there's so much big stuff
happening this summer all my links for my marvel
episode videos are down in the description below
and my obi-wan kenobi bonus videos everyone click
here for that brand new black adam trailer video
i'll update the link as soon as i post it and
click here for my qui-gon jin easter egg video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!